welcome back to coffee Zilla so excited
to be back with you guys finished with
the vacation and we're back grinded
content so expect some regular stuff
from me make sure you've hit the bell
guys there's how many times does Anna
Anka have to tell you smash like
unsubscribe guys I have a lot to tell
you about my vacation went very well and
more importantly I found something
pretty incredible on the trip not a lot
of you know this because I keep it
pretty private because it's embarrassing
it's an embarrassing fact about me I
have a large head okay
it's many sizes too large it's
uncomfortably large and I've never been
able to find a hat that fits me like no
baseball caps
it'll be on that you know how you can
like snap it together it's on the last
run and it's like not fitting me so
that's a constant problem that I have
all my sunglasses glasses are always
bent out because my head's too fat so
I've always had that problem and I'm
always on the lookout for hats and on
this trip let's just say I found the
perfect hat so big ups for that that's
basically made the whole trip a success
but I also got something this month I'm
not I've got physical objects I don't
really care about stuff but this has
been quite the month for getting things
that are pretty amazing because uh guys
this might be my favorite physical
object so far and that's from somebody
with a wedding ring here what I have
right here I've been meaning to show you
guys this for some time
but before I show you what it is let me
tell you a little story okay a couple
weeks ago I did the Jordan Harbinger
show now Jordan harbingers popular
podcaster I'll link our show together
below but on it I started to tell him
about the fake Harvard speeches story
which is one of my favorite stories I
always talk about it with fakery where
we exposed this like organization that
was running fake Harvard speeches and
people were paying to get on these
things for marketing material and all of
a sudden Jordan Harbinger says oh my
gosh I was a part of that I was fooled
into being a part of this Clint artha
thing and it's like this hilarious story
during the show you again you can go
watch it below but after the show he
told me Steven I've got a mug from that
event if you wanted so
maybe one of the greatest busts of my
lifetime
this guy has memorabilia from that thing
from being there at this thing he goes I
was gonna throw it away I could send it
to you if you want I said Jordan I'll
pay any price for this mug for this icon
of fraudster ISM anything for this thing
and he goes you got it I'm gonna send it
right away so you can see right there
coffee Zilla
from Jordan Harvard or 20/20 check it
out baby
okay we're official now so not only did
I fake a Harvard speech using clean
Arthur's method thank you to everyone
who invited me to speak at this
prestigious university but now I now
officially have a mug from that event so
there you go guys that is coming full
circle if I've ever seen it I'm sorry I
don't think I'll ever take this off the
fit of the great mug wall okay it's my
it's my new most prized possession
beautiful and with that I want to tell
you guys two more things okay that's for
two more things one of which is I'm
investigating Clint Arthur again again
that's the guy who did the fake Harvard
speeches we'll get into that in a second
but let me also say real quick as an
aside I need your help with some
trending tab crowd-sourced data we did
this year ago two years ago we did a big
video on the training tab it got a
million views featured on PewDiePie's
channel i mean insane what 40,000 videos
tell us about the trending tab this
YouTube recalled coffee break and a
cornerstone of that research project was
you guys on this channel helping me
crowdsource data if you want to be a
part of that project we're running it
again yeah hopefully we can do it it
should be like done in 24 hours or so if
we get enough people involved I'll link
the video below in the descriptions if
you want to help out there's a whole
video describing how you can help how
you
basically I need you to classify
different youtubers and if you want to
be a part of that you want to be a part
of the video let me know just click on
the link below and finally I want to say
this guys I thought the Clint Arthur
thing was over because there's this
whole article about how he's done with
Harvard Harvard said they don't want
anything to do with him
and that's when I saw a new video
surface of Clint Arthur not in his
normal spot his normal Harvard space but
in a new Harvard space and instead of
his phony Harvard logo it was like the
real actual Harvard logo with like this
Harvard Club of Boston crest in the
background and people are speaking again
and this was uploaded in like 2019 and I
was like oh my gosh it's Clint Arthur
back in business this would be the
greatest thing ever and so I thought to
myself if there's another Harvard event
going on I want to be a part of it I
want to go up on that stage and speak on
the stage it's the look this is as close
as I think I'm ever gonna get but if I
could get closer I'll do anything to get
up on that stage so I called Klein
Arthur up and here's what happened check
mic check mic check
hello hi can you hear me okay yeah sorry
about that
I I don't know what happened to my phone
my name is Bob Doyle I was wondering
about this Harvard Club of Boston if
you're still doing that how much it
costs to be a part of that kind of thing